[Musica]
anni a sky la sedia
[Applauso]
bella tutti ragazzi e perdendo questo
video sono fa vj che sono ancora con la
maglia di peter con quanta fierezza me
la metto stamane la retina ed al secolo
che non facevo da mesi praticamente che
non facciamo video colo colo state
quindi faccio di registrare che non devo
imparare a pulirle le cose quando le use
pieno di capelli c'entra poco
nel frattempo gli faccio uno shampoo
allora lega soli ci siamo siamo in
titanic ragazzi che dovrebbe essere la
versione plus lift della vicenda del
titanic credo quella del film voi non lo
vedete ma io lo vedo c'è leonardo di
caprio laggiù che si sta per suicidare e
chiedendo l'oscar però è lei la ragazzi
partiamo prima che vengono provato
niente di sta roba quindi diamo
un'occhiata a bello ci siamo solo
spostati di qualche metro ma sai che
buono come cazzo già i superpoteri
ragazzi si scopre che sono superman
senti oddio posso suicidarmi per davvero
ma cosa ma cuore ma allora cos'è
sacrosanti dio sia affogato ho capito
non pensavo ci si potesse butta giù sul
serio dai ragazzi abbiamo capito che non
sono fatto per per i naufragi io cioè io
muoio superto ragazzi qualcuno mi spiega
perchè non c'è il cornicione quindi si
sono dimenticati di metter la ringhiera
fatevi capito che io sono di caprio
pretendo una bella [ __ ] non ho mai visto
nella mia vita una nave così spoglia non
c'è nessuno o cristo
o cristo no ragazzi cè un cubetto un po
grosso lì la mia il tratto io mi sono
teletrasportato non chiedetemi come
prova dei ragazzi
dovreste bravi nodi più dato il quasi st
capitano in teoria non ci sto io
perché io non so guida chi è che sta
guidando se io sul capitano ma i fatti
stanno schiantando grazie a cazzo faccio
finta di girare ma non so il timone non
un cazzo quindi valore dai fan in grazie
ormai ecco league era scaduta la nave
fantastico cia out leonardo a 90 grosso
dichiara veramente così grosso l'iceberg
[ __ ] vacca tuttofare skydiving da qui
sopra è come al solito lo scarso
infiliamo né alcuno bravo leonardo
ragazzi mi da un senso di inquietudine
che non avete idea
cos'è oddio no è mai lasciato un'altra
volta il lavandino aperto [ __ ] eva ma
ciò mi sono pisciato addosso dove cazzo
siano beveva beh mi chiamo come hai
fatto benissimo che sta cosa è fatta
veramente bene rende troppo l'idea
ciao non sono stato io e io non ci avevo
neanche il demone appunto per quello ci
sia schiantarlo e surf to activate in
flash drive ma perché c'è la torcia come
negli horror cazzo io sono rose e devo
andare a salvare leonardo che sta con le
manette datemi un ascia e dategli uno
oscar certo c'è che interagisce con
alcuni oggetti compresa le porte
premendo è sta fumando jack è pronto il
pollo questo cancello è chiusa a chiave
deve esserci una chiave da qualche parte
ok
leonardo leo portacci mia quanta acqua
cioè fatemi ebbene sì ne avevo bisogno
che unar dello poor's kevin permesso
devo trovare un qualche cosa per aprirla
e che con cosa la pro qualcuno che viene
ad arona sei stata la porta per corse
sia qualcuno che apra madonna pubblico
zio stare con la testa così dai media
altro favoloso lato metro e 20 sono alto
pure palazzo mio dove sanno cos'è sta un
vaso di piccone tasso al momento
perfetto per giocare a mike credo che
con questo io ci tengo a sfondo alla
porta però mi devo muovere perché un
altro po a fuoco ai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai dove qua spanda cioè cioè ho
trovato il diamante
oddio c'è una sedia c'è un letto ad
almeno mi faccio riposino un lavandino
perfetto nuovo si una bella rinfrescata
che hanno disidratato cazzola si posso
mandare foglio 10 gesù sono già morto
vienimi a salvare jack ti prego su
qualcosa di meglio dell'oscar ti
proteggo prometto ti da ciò la passera è
una chiave quella che erano chiare sul
piatto ma ditelo di gesù ma che ne so
vincerò adesso così è scomparsa la porta
legato sono houdini fantastico siamo
fuori sono libero
no non è vero non sono i va dai dai dai
c'è qualcuno su questa maledetta nacro
ci sono solo io fatemi capire non tanto
dio
cos'è sembra che ci sia tanta pressione
d'acqua dietro questa porta
ma non lo apriamo
io sì che so sopravvivere alle
catastrofi cazzo se sono capaci e c'è un
lucchetto
serve una chiave tanto per cambiare
serve una chiave alcune porte potrebbero
sfondarsi quando subiscono tanta
pressione sott'acqua ok allora forse
potrei aver capito non credevo corner e
ci siamo ci siete mai
ma ecco la cola cola trovata è quella di
prima con lucchetto credo che si apra
cui e spero iddio madonna a prestiti
prego iddio abbia preti si va fatta la
prima bastava un calcio a quel punto dio
mio
dimmi che gli ascensori si aprono sono
cielo nel culo c'era nel culo c'era nel
culo sono purissimo c'è un eclissi ma
porca eva sbaglio sempre strada
maledizione dove vado
di qua scale ci passi da qua dai sì
deficiente ma ci passi in un secondo
beck deck cazzo e yu gi oh
mac os è aperto tutto alla tutto
allagato tutto allagato ti deve morire
la famiglia dove sto andando ragazze non
so neanch'io tronco in faccia
ma vi rendete conto che non ri e non
riesce a superare questa roba ma vi
rendete conto ti devi abbassare
cioè male alle ginocchia hai paura di
sporcarsi i piedini gesù madonna 6 di
quanto può essere a grazie a 46 sempre
molto gentile con me
certo manca sul web guarda o 78 grave
leveque perchè non potevi abbassati dove
aspettare che l'acqua di aprire nel
passaggio certo pausa merenda ragazzi
pausa merenda la pausa non senti la
campanella
cavezzana dai dai dai dai dai dai certo
sempre la strada sbagliata
aprite dai che va beh sì certo è ovvio
sono moltissimo che cazzo dove devo
andare
ragazzi dove devo andare o si avverta
che allora si scemo ma prima era chiusa
ragazzi però non è giusto o so cercato
non lo so chi cazzo è successo è entrata
una balena vai vai vai vai non sono
anche più dove sto andando vai e basta t
ra dove c'è meno acqua se non si aprono
le porte sono morto a prima qualcuno che
mi dia una mano porca eva sono una
donzella sono una donzella ambiente la
[ __ ] non interessa più a nessuno quando
si affoga nessuno guarda in faccia
nessuno sia presa o di oh di qua oh dio
dio dio di hardy su su su dio ti
ringrazio delle scale che porta al suo
capitano
non sono stato io giuro che non sono
stato io non la pago io tanto buio a me
c'è la nutella in frigo questa non è la
nutella amico mio mi sa che non è
proprio nutella prove e 40 minuti che
corro con un deficiente da soli prego
c'è qualcuno su st nave cos'è seriamente
ci deve essere un altra via a perché
tutto infilato non posso passare scusami
sedia ti giuro ti avrei salvata devo
abbandonarti qui sedia non giudicarmi
per questo
ho una chiave neanche gli ha senso
qualcosa si apre ecco la forchetta
quanto ancora devo salire prima di
arrivare al ponte per cortesia ancora no
però siccome ci sono le luci accese
credo che manchi pochissimo quanto che a
quanto era in fondo la nave quanto bella
sa musica cos'è skrillex dolce melodia
stavo scherzando che merda via via via
via siamo nel punto pc cos'è a questa è
la stanza del capitano la mia stanza se
ho fatto proprio il mio dovere
fantastico via cazzo io sono uscito non
ci credo mai siamo salvi ragazzi visto
che figata grandissimo una nave da
crociera incredibile utilizzata per
trasportare un [ __ ] passeggero uno
solo perché non c'è nessun altro che
cazzo sono tutti e scialuppe sono tutte
a posto non c'è nessun so solo io ma che
non avevo detto a mia madre che non
volevano dannare lo prende a barca a
vela
io si sta incrinando tutto che brutta
cosa bye bye bye bye bye bye bye vedevo
andare lì sopra l'ultimo ecco ci siamo
sono nel punto giusto c'è un'asta
ragazzi che foto che volete dirmi che
mando in fila nel culo però vedo se
riesco a trovare un'altra soluzione non
c'è scritto qualcosa lì c'è una specchia
c'è un caso di testo che non avevo visto
cos'ha scritto da dove viene il rumore
di quella campanella quale campanella è
vero oddio c'è una scialuppa ce ne sono
sono superman merda lo manca a non l'ho
presa da presa
pallotta italy ma cosa è finito così una
domanda mi sono lanciato da 50 metri ho
preso una scialuppa in faccia non mi
sono fatto niente comunque sia ragazzi
quando è che me lo date l'oscar andò
gazo stiamo andando alla scialuppa
quelli andiamo da mia zia capita più o
meno ii e chi mai avrà vinto l'oscar
quest'anno anni asca
la sedia
[Applauso]
sento gesù che c'è è chiara ragazzi ce
l'abbiamo fatta ciò che ci ho messo la
vita e mezzo ammirazione di dio che non
mi sono trovato in una situazione del
genere sul serio perché sarei affogato
16 mila volt è stato veramente assurdo
perché dava dava sul serio l'idea di
annegamento cioè era veramente pesante
però spero che aiuto vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi spero che leonardo vinca l'oscar
un mi piace servito è piaciuto mi piace
se voi sapete notare meglio di me però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa è
subito piaciuto ha commentato mi piace
anche capace di facebook e cavani di 80
le iscrizioni sono i resti di scafi ci
vediamo un po se ho vinto o ad un
prossimo naufragio ma è bella ragazza